i've had had clients tell me ah
beautiful florence they thought they
were in florence
naturally one must say yes because you
can never open anyone
of all harmful animals the most harmful
is the tourist robert gilbert 1871
[Music]
the art city is nothing more than a
museum full of foreigners who have moved
their own habits
standhall 1820.
if we have to put the bid of nails for
the indian the chopsticks for the
chinese
or only a bathtub for the japanese and
they don't eat polenta with brassato
then it's best they stay home if they
come here i will offer them polenta and
brazato
we know that having told everyone that
one of the results of climate change is
that the polar bears are dying out this
has caused a 300 increase really the
flights to go see the polar bears before
they disappear
in 2016 there were a billion
235 million tourists worldwide in less
than 10 years in 2030 we estimate that
there will be a billion and 800 million
all these people around the world
looking for relaxation things to see
places where they must go all together
all at the same time
and like everything else
it's that too much that is a problem
especially in some of the more
fashionable destinations the phenomena
is called over tourism and it is
changing the look and economic order of
many cities
as you can see the gondolas the poor
guys trying to do their work in the
middle of this traffic taxi is
everywhere
until 12 in the morning we cannot
circulate with our boats on the grand
canal it is reserved for tourism in a
city that means taxi gondola cargo and
such
venus now has the same air quality as
milan and we live in a pedestrian city
where we have all the disadvantage of
having to carry heavy bags on foot
we have the pollution of cities where
people go around with cars
here everything is diesel
vaporetti taxi transport boats they all
have diesel engines
look at the traffic here and it's not
even rush hour
we are selling the city for the sake of
tourism
not like the days of the vatican
criticisms who knew how to organize
things no it has become a regular mass
prostitution
these are the conditions in which the
gondoliers work at present imagine the
silence when canalito painted the grand
canal with the acoustic pollution that
you hear passing under the bridge
marco casparinetti is a lawyer who began
the 25th april group
a symbolic name the date of the italian
liberation to fight to keep venice from
being suffocated by tourism to put an
end for example of building and
transforming homes into hotels
especially if it is done by a public
entity
the court has a seat in this beautiful
white place palazzo di camalengi but all
this area now
risks speculation
and seeing the setting it is easy to
imagine what type of appetites will be
witted
at the moment the vatican court is
housed here and it will surely be sold
in 2019 by the city of venice to turn it
into another hotel
the adjacent building is also sure to be
sold
after a large march organized by us last
year more than two thousand persons on
rival delhi shivani the mayor had
promised no more hotels in venice
enough we already have too many so he
said okay we will make them anjudeka
morano maestre when they need to spread
tourism throughout the city territory
there are thousands of new hotel
accommodations being built right now in
maestre
the mayor's answer right now is but in
mystery they go to see mastery or even
worse we can also take care of tourists
going to gesorro
josuro is 40 kilometers from the hotel i
can just imagine under the august sun
the tourists and flip-flops marching
single file from maestre to cesaro let's
not kid ourselves i believe that the
mayor underestimated the intelligence of
the venetians if they built new hotels
in maestre it's not for tourists going
to jessaro it is because tourists want
to see venice
barcelona is going through a similar
situation where there are regularly
graffiti against tourists also here
there are groups that contrast the
phenomenon
not all using the same methods
we are very careful not to attack
tourists because they are not guilty
it is logical that people do not
empathize with tourists because they are
the main sign
they are what we see when we perceive
this worsening of our own lifestyle
the question to ask should be why are
they all here or why everyone
in venice
there is a spectacular concentration in
certain tourist spots around the world
and it is not casual
it is not the tourists came by choice
they come because there is a propaganda
machine for tourism that puts it in
everyone's head that barcelona is the
place you have to go and if you don't
then you are nothing
and
it is not always a marketing operation
that attracts tourists last year a video
on youtube was enough to start an
exceptional flux of people to valor
vezaska known as a maldives close to
milan
video last year was a good thing since
there was a boom especially of italians
however
everyone worked the restaurants
businesses everyone
but the mess that was left afterwards
there were clean persons who took care
of their garbage and others who threw
away beer and coca-cola cans and this
was not a good thing for verzasca it was
degrading
last year i noticed this after the video
about the maldives of milano came out
there was a boom of italian tourists it
was a radical change the swimmers all
have a correct way of acting in what
they leave behind
the arrival of so many people in a small
area of the valley created lots of
criticism
this year things have changed
the residents don't want to be
interviewed to not create hard feelings
and the towns of the valley and pro
local of verzaska have organized parking
more garbage bins
than chemical toilets to help out the
restaurants
some of which against crowds wanting to
only use their facilities close to
protests
not to mention the greatest service the
prevention of health problems that is
not always an easy thing
some listen and some could care less
after all what can we do we predict we
use preventive measures but if no one
listens then anything can happen
that's how it is
and it often happens right before our
eyes a woman who went too far into the
current was rescued clumsily by her
friends
before official rescuers could come she
was able to get to safety and with a bit
of a scare
perhaps she didn't even realize that she
had just risked her life
we have lots of girls who go around
giving help to prevent problems they
give out cards telling what to watch out
for
how can we tell them as they go out into
the current watch out it's dangerous
it often happens that when on vacation
especially abroad people sometimes take
risks or are rude
there was a group of german swiss boys
who wanted to dive in a risky zone up in
aquino
and i stepped in telling them not to
dive
they fooled around and when they were in
the water they asked for help just to
make fun of our work
the growth of tourist numbers also means
unfortunately more bad behavior
i think that rudeness has always existed
and the growth of mass tourism only
makes this more evident not only in
tourism in general a person in jacket
and thai acts in a completely different
way from a person in a bathing suit
i don't know what mechanism happens to
make them change but perhaps it's the
freedom
the fact that they are not in the office
in their normal role and they can let
themselves go
i have direct experience where a
swimming pool seemed like a nursery
school because of all the things that
happened you would need a book to tell
libero
it's not just the lack of the correct
clothing polite behavior is not an
object that is part of the tourist kid
needs a lot of patience to do our work
it is something we like to do otherwise
we wouldn't be doing it every day we
have to deal with completely different
people with different cultures way of
doing things and sensibilities
no one wants to speak badly about their
clients but there are some antidotes
some clients use their reviews to gain
services that they wouldn't otherwise
have or perhaps they wouldn't have had
the possibility of having there
i remember one client who told me that
if he had to pay for parking he would
leave a bad review
and sometimes there are even robberies
the ashtray the spoon the bathrobe we
have even had a painting and television
stolen
this happened where i worked for before
by a person in jacket and tie
it's not the poor person who can't pay
but in luxury hotel
this person asked the porter for a box
called the reception said in 10 minutes
come up there is something to bring down
to my car he had packed up the tv in the
box gave the porter 10 francs ticked and
went away with the tv
these things are unfortunate isolated
cases
more bothersome is that side of
overcrowding tourism that makes it seem
that tourist is more important than the
residents
of india
no would you please give me a glass of
white wine
wanda very well two glasses of white
wine
overtourism in tecino is already known i
remember in the 70s beginning of the 80s
with marco solari as director of
tecino's tourism board where he tried to
make ascona german speaking because
everything in ascona was written only in
germany
oh
[Music]
it is a situation that older people
remember well
thanks to a hidden camera that went on
air in the weekly program reporter in
1979.
tourism existed before but it was
different the tourists went to coastal
beach areas
in these areas there were not so many
residents the land was empty so they
could expand
now we speak of over tourism because it
is happening in the cities
the weekend break in the city has grown
huge
and the key to short city vacation is
that tourists come to your home
tourists are not alone in your city they
are also in your condominium
you find them everywhere and distance
between residents and tourists is not
sufficient
the local population does not have a
space where they can go and say this is
mine
this is mine
mass tourism began back in july 1841 in
leicester
a northern english town
thomas cook a baptist minister was
worried about the excessive drinking of
his town's workers
to distract them he organized sunday
trips by train up to lobber
11 miles away more than 500 people went
it was the first of an infinite series
of organized travel
the steam engine between the two cities
is still there
the route is practically the same
but today we met professor xavier
front of the university of surrey who
studies strategies of handling the
phenomenon born on this railway
there are many solutions if there is the
political will
there are some large companies that are
growing very quickly there are online
travel agencies that are not personally
interested in any one city
they only have a commercial interest
this translates in a growth of prices of
the residents who are thrown out because
they can no longer find reasonably
priced living spaces
we are in the gothic quarter of
barcelona in the center
and here we are at plaza medellin
it is a very interesting place to
explain but really very sad
this is a piazza that 30 years ago was
full of life
around here it was all residential and
now no one lives here anymore we have
hotel hotel luxury hotel luxury
residence but not on the level that
people who lived here
here is a piazza with no more
residential life because all the people
who pass by are here for four days to
see the city and then go away
it is a hit and run tourism that runs
the trolley wheels over your feet
over the inhabitants and the economic
balance
immediate bad feelings are caused by
low-cost mass tourism where thousands of
people are herded in droves from one
place to another of the city
and when they are exhausted they sit on
the monuments and eat in the street
those who criticize them don't realize
that they do not have much choice
one who comes with little money brings a
sandwich and sits to eat in the piazza
said marco
you say you cannot do this
you must say you cannot do this here but
over there are some beautiful gardens
where you can't have a big table
for one euro you can sit down and have
students who clean up this is being
civilized showing the visitors who
arrive your civilization
instead you only see stalls horrendous
stalls where they sell stuff from taiwan
this is our own fault the fault of the
city
in one of his books define himself as a
prisoner in a room
that is his restaurant a very famous
harry's bar
a must go to place for all those who
count
would like to see his city able to
handle the phenomenon of tourists
overcrowding better
market was the most beautiful
supermarket the world had
now is nothing
it has become a mass of stalls that sell
everything
instead markets have always been the
heart of the city
markets considered typical are
privileged places for tourists searching
for authentic
but because of their mass numbers the
tourists destroy what they were looking
instead of basic necessities the stalls
sell souvenirs and then the residents go
away
to avoid this problem the city of
barcelona now wants to prohibit tourists
from entering the food market on the
rambolus used to be able to shop here
but now it's hard even to enter
i live here at the end of the rambolas
and many people go to the center
katarina market
i also go often to other places because
here is difficult to even get inside
there are always a lot of tourists
the market people can earn from tourism
but the market should also be for the
people of the neighborhood not
not only tourists you need to try and
make everyone happy
[Music]
do you think there are too many tourists
i don't think so the only thing to do
would be to choose a bit of tourism
we don't want mass tourism but good
tourism yes
there are a lot of people does that
bother you
yes sometimes
however it makes it lively
certainly we protest a lot but it gives
life
for the elderly who sit on the benches
of the rambolas chatting as they used to
do in front of their houses
the tourists are not a problem
do you think there are too many tourists
no no i like it there are all kinds of
people some like it some don't
some are bothered
[Music]
see
yes i like it
here you can see everything
in summer you see people going around
almost nude
and other with coats
there is just about everything
i like it
but even for those that are not bothered
by the tourists but making a living off
them
things are beginning to be worrying
i think that we all must find where the
limit is because to only use tourism for
money until i die okay but in some ways
i am killing my economy
because if in the end there will be
fewer tourists because the place is not
as interesting and it is being ruined
what people came to see
it's not good either for the tourists
the tourist says i want to see how
people live here not how tourists live
here
for that i could stay home
when i go to a place i really want to
learn about it
[Music]
[Music]
as a consultant for many cities
including barcelona is trying to give a
solution
to barcelona i suggested to change its
type of marketing
to invest less money in marketing and
more money in managing the destination
they must stop making it the object of
growth and see it as a synonym for
success
true success is being able to attract
tourists that help the residences
well-being grow and
to discourage hit and run tourism
avoid the concentration in the same
places
and help a certain integration with the
resident population
this is more or less what is defending
the city of barcelona
what substantially consists in tourism
management
not to question the status quo the
actual situation of tourism in the city
but try to manage it better
for example if the buses are full put
more buses
the day that there will no longer be
buses on the street
they will make more streets
or perhaps we'll go ahead without
putting the situation in doubt
as an assembly of the quarter we have
proposed a reduction of the importance
of tourism for the city's economy so it
will not become a tourism monopoly which
we practically are
economia
um
[Music]
for the most famous tourist places it is
difficult to resist the sirens of
tourism and its earnings
in venice the area around the arsenal
was once very populated there were
hundreds of workers living there
then the arsenal closed
and the jobs disappeared
today little by little this area next to
the panel is becoming prey for those who
want to make it a new tourist corridor
grew up in switzerland and for a long
time has lived in venice she knows this
quarter very well
there used to be a fruit and vegetable
shop here
now it is closed and there's a private
storage
upstairs there are only tourist
apartments no one lives here anymore
here there was a
carpenter now it's just a storage place
in this campello there are only tourist
apartments everything has been
transformed into apartments for visitors
this is the only food shop remaining on
this island of san martino
well i would say that lately because of
the lack of a resident population not
very well
once the lack of inhabitants was filled
in by the tourists
now instead tourism is so massive that
even that is not enough to cover costs
and things
[Music]
there is no more fabric to the city
sometimes the tourist comes and asks me
for a certain thing and i have to tell
them to go to the master to get it
because here we don't have it anymore
then when there are these lags we lose
the fabric we lose everything
the traditions
the scene
is a student in urban anthropology and
studies the changes that have happened
in venice since the end of the war
this has become the area of the moldova
in venice with an incredible
concentration of bars that are pushing
out other activities this is because the
rents the bars are able to pay in venice
are much higher than those another
regular commercial businesses can pay
a general raise has accelerated the
exodus of the population
the city of water the island city has
lost more than two-thirds of its
inhabitants since the 1950s
today there are only 54 000 inhabitants
thus a very small population
this means there has been a huge change
in the economic structure of the city
that has gradually seen tourism become
the principal activity and today almost
exclusive activity of the city of water
these
in these last few years because of the
unnatural and exponential growth of the
tourism sector
tourism is not a spontaneous phenomenon
it is a produced one that has
motivations and conditions it is not
eternal because it is based on specific
historic conditions such as low cost of
fuel and low cost of transportation hate
holidays all things that today we take
for granted but who knows if tomorrow
they will still be available
what frightened us is that once
destroyed the fabric of a nation's
society will be difficult to restore
the venetians i spoke with cannot see a
future they see a process that tends to
get only worse and some answer
i hope i won't be around i hope i will
already be dead
[Music]
the venetians are mistaken because the
venetian was open to the world and now
instead he has become a tiny provincial
this hurts the venetians and also these
tourists
i would understand if it was an invading
army
but it's not an invasion
i see them being rude on the boats the
vaporetti they push the people
that is what the venetians who have
remained due
is wrong we are giving the impression of
a dead city
86 years of age has a more optimistic
view of vanessa's future
has gone through many stories with many
plagues before the plague there were
2500 000 people
after the plague only 50 000
and the city was always rebuilt
therefore i consider this a descending
phase a moment in a historic environment
the ebb and flow of history teach us
that also beauty has not always survived
changes
to conserve it as intact as possible is
the job of each generation
[Music]
you